the scene is indelibly imprinted on
anyone who's been to college row after
row of students gazing down as a
professor or a ta drones on about
chemical bonds or the byzantine empire
the long lecture is widely accepted as
an economical and effective way to
educate large groups of students but in
a piece for time magazine salman khan
argues that even the most brilliant
speaker and the most compelling subject
won't hold students attention for more
than 18 minutes so call and tell us
about the lecture you remember best 800
email us talk npr.org you can also join
the conversation on our website that's
at npr.org click on talk of the nation
salman khan is founder of the khan
academy author of the one world
schoolhouse education reimagined and
joins us now from a studio in stanford
california nice to have you with us
today
great to be here and what is it that
makes those lectures so boring
what is it
well i think all of us could uh answer
that in a very anecdotal way uh but you
know what what i think a lot of people
don't realize is that there's actually
been been research in this space to
study the lecture and it's it's pretty
decisive it's never been really
contradicted that people can pay
attention for about 10 to 18 minutes
after which they start zoning out then
they can kind of re-check in for about
10 minutes then they zone out for an
even longer period of time and that
keeps going on and studies have shown
that when you when you do lecture at
someone that you actually retain some of
the early information you retain very
little of the the latter information and
and just as you described a lot of the
reason why we do it this way is is
really logistics logistics come from a
coming from a reality where we didn't
have any other technologies to deliver
the information so we for the most part
in colleges and k through 12 around the
the world we still have a bunch of
students sitting there for 60 to 90
minutes uh being lectured at
well that
vacillating attention span you talked
about you can you could miss out on
entire faronic dynasties
no no that's exactly right and you know
there it hasn't gone completely
unrecognized there have been attempts to
address this issue uh you know i talk
about it in this in the book uh that
that there have been professors that try
to do these change-ups try to ask
questions try to do little group things
every 10 or 15 minutes to address this
issue but what i point out is that
that's a bit of a that's a bit of a
halfway fix uh what we really should
think is well is is this class time this
time that all these human beings get
together is lecture even the best the
best use of that well uh you've got to
convey a certain amount of information
to in in certainly in the in the case of
college introduction courses a whole
bunch of people at the same time
that's right and and uh 200 years ago i
probably couldn't have come up with a
better way of doing that
but now we have
very on-demand ways to access media
obviously things like youtube obviously
things like khan academy what i work on
but there's other efforts there's edx
that mit and harvard are doing where and
a lot of med schools have actually been
doing this for a little while where
students are getting the information
delivery the lecture at their own time
and pace and and there are benefits to
that because
you can pause if there's a word you
don't understand you could look it up on
the internet you can go ask a friend if
you forgot a little bit of your view
material from a couple of years ago no
need to be
embarrassed and raise your hand in the
middle of class and stop everyone's
learning you can you can go review that
material and you don't have to take
notes because it's it's always there and
then when you go to when you go to class
time you can use that for something more
valuable like like a conversation or a
project or some type of peer-to-peer
learning but isn't it also the student's
responsibility to uh uh absorb some of
this knowledge
it is it is and it's it's always going
to be the the student's responsibility
in fact i think that's the whole point
of why that's why i think lecture misses
is that the other day learning is a
is something that the student has to
decide to do and you know at the
university level especially i've always
said you know it'd be interesting to
just administer a final exam two days
before students thought that they were
going to get the final exam and and see
what the delta is and you'll see that
very little of the learning or at least
as measured by the final exam
occurs in the first you know 90 of the
class it's it's really the last two
three days before the exam students are
cramming and teaching each other and and
that's what's really at least moving the
dial on their exams i wonder you said
and and you don't have to take notes if
you can have electronic copies of of the
lectures uh digital copies that you can
go back and refer to
doesn't the act of taking notes uh help
you learn
the act of doing anything does help you
learn uh fundamentally if if you are
passive in anything you're probably not
that engaged and i think a lot of
students do take notes literally just to
stay awake literally to be engaged a lot
of students they don't you know they
don't use the notes later on it's just
really to somewhat stay engaged but that
that that's the whole point if if we
want students to stay engaged going
through this exercise of taking notes
while
listening to a lecture and oftentimes
not being able to listen because they're
taking notes
let's just make it more active instead
of doing these change ups every 10 or 15
minutes let's make the whole classroom
change up so let's make the whole
classroom students teaching each other
students having a conversation with each
other the one thing i point out a lot in
the book is you know we talk about this
human experience of of of education but
when students are sitting in a classroom
up and and there's someone lecturing at
them maybe they're taking notes you're
in a room with 30 maybe 300 other people
at the college level that's a very
dehumanizing experience i've sat in
classes uh for the whole semester and i
didn't know 98 of those people i didn't
know their names uh what what we're
really advocating and we're starting to
see in a lot of schools and universities
is well
let's have those 300 people interact
with each other instead of having a
study group just the last three days
before the exam why don't we have it for
the whole semester
a study group of 300 it's not a class
it's a potential riot
no no that's right and i think i think
that's where technology comes in again
uh you know one it can it can help
deliver some of the information that
lectures used to do
but now you can also coordinate you can
see where every students are on in kind
of their skill levels you can pair them
up you can give diagnostics uh to the
teacher and you know the whole point of
you know some people say well
well students might not listen to
lecture if it's if it's happening at
home and and and and you know before
they had homework that could have been
checked and and what i point out and
most people agree with this is that the
the homework or the problem solving is
where where the learning is happening
and so if students are going to check
out of one of the two things i i would
say make sure it's not the problem
solving
going back to your days as a student
though are there are there lectures that
you remember uh particularly vividly
the uh well i talk a lot in the book and
and you know my own experience in
undergrad i i talk about i was a bit of
a chronic class skipper and not i think
well sometimes out of laziness but for
the most part it was just out of finding
the most productive use of my time and i
discovered there was this whole
world this was at mit of people who just
never went to class and just would use
that time to do problem solving uh
instead and so um
for the most part the ones that were
memorable were the ones where there was
a shared experience and i don't want you
know there were some great orators some
great lecturers some that were inspiring
uh but but it was good for for moments
but it wasn't great when you were trying
to dig deep into something when you
might be a little bit lost and you want
to catch up but the class is going at a
pace you might be a little bit bored you
might know the material already um it i
i think the shared experience of a of a
lecture is great for inspirational
things it's great for things that aren't
a super deep in terms of uh uh kind of
they're the substantive nature um i
think those type of things can happen on
demand at your own pace and then and
then class time is all about problem
solving we're talking with uh salman
khan founder of the khan academy a
non-profit that creates online
educational videos he's the author of
the one world schoolhouse education
reimagine we want to hear today from you
about the college lecture you vividly
remember
800-989-8255 email talk npr.org
benjamin's on the line with us from fort
wayne hi there hi
so what i remember out of all the
lectures that i i've had in college is
from my sociology class uh robert pettit
he's a great sociology teacher um he
uh was using visuals along with his uh
speech and he was teaching us about
socially constructed realities and
basically he was petting a an invisible
cat on his desk
and
was saying you know if you if we all
believe there was a cab here then
therefore
it does exist
and it was really interesting and so i
found that uh incorporating
visuals with
you know speaking speaking uh made it
uh easier to remember more likely to
remember
and clearly you remember that one how
long ago was that
that was i would say two years ago oh so
that's not all that long ago no not no
not at all all right thanks very much
for the phone call appreciate it thank
you so even uh even some simple uh
devices uh acting out and and some some
visuals uh salman khan can help it can
help somewhat
and and and you know i it sounds like
that was a great instructor a great
lecturer uh but what i would say is is
that actually he should share those
skills and it sounds like he was
humorous and all the rest i mean that
that that instructor should make videos
put him online his students could access
them and then when they go to class they
can actually have that debate about
whether if everyone believes the cat is
there whether it really is there let's
see if we go to uh james and james is
with us from montrose in colorado
hi neil uh yeah i just wanted to share
my really my most memorable and
this little instance was the only memory
that i have of the entire semester in
this
class physical geography
where my professor was
teaching for the first time in america
from china
and nobody could understand a word she
said until she made one comment about
how she uh recently arrived in america
and a friend called her from china
and uh she's you know trying to describe
the the earth rotation around the sun
and how days and nights are different on
different sides of the planet
and her friend says oh hi how are you
doing and she said well how the hell do
you think i'm doing it's three in the
morning i'm sleeping
that was the only bit that me and
probably 175 other students taught
for three and a half plus months how'd
you do on the course
okay you know
that was about 12 and a half years ago
i want to say i did pretty well i
enjoyed the class but you know honestly
i can't remember the look of it
and i guess uh salman khan thanks very
much for the call james uh that makes
your point
yeah that's exactly i mean you know most
of us can't remember actually the
courses we took and i'm not that far out
of college but uh much less the the
actual content of a lot of it and even
when you were there uh you know running
up to the final exam it's this is why
there's so many students cramming is
that they've they've learned very little
they've gone through the motions they
feel like they're paying tuition it's
part of the i guess the the ceremony of
going to college of uh showing up at
these lectures because that seems to be
what everyone else is doing but i've
actually found that the students that
are most productive are the ones that
use that time to go do something else an
email from allen in augusta georgia of
thousands of lectures i've enjoyed the
best is no doubt jack pettigrew's love
is a plastic state i heard this as a
student in his neurophysiology class in
caltech in 1975 but he delivered it
elsewhere as well the point was to
discuss neuronal plasticity how our
brains change and he illustrated it with
numerous anecdotes including how his
brother-in-law lost his fear of the
deadly snake while high jack really
eliminated the subject the impact of
evolution on brain states we're talking
with solomon khan about uh lectures and
reimagining them you're listening to
talk of the nation from npr news
let's go next to richard and richard is
with us from sioux city in iowa hi hello
everybody nice uh nice program thank you
thanks for having me on uh i teach
mindfulness and i was in a mindfulness
course at university of missouri quite a
few years ago a graduate level course
the first lecture about mindfulness was
actually started with eating a raisin
and where we uh
the raisins were passed out and the idea
is we're going to focus our attention on
all of the sensuous aspects of the
raisin before we even taste it before we
put it in our mouth and mindfulness as
you may know is of course the the entire
process of controlling your attentional
awareness
and the intent of mindfulness is that we
train our minds so that they don't drift
away or drift forward or drift back and
we do have more disciplined thinking
processes
and did it work after 18 minutes or so
with the raising
yeah i'd say with that course it really
did because it was an eight-week course
and it it absolutely uh it absolutely
helps to discipline your again your
attentional awareness where is your
attention at this very moment is it
where it should be or not
and as a person who now
prepares and teaches those programs for
a couple of schools
uh i can tell you it does work and it
may be something that would be be of
interest or that your your guests may
already be of which they may already be
aware salman khan are you aware of
mindfulness yeah well i i think that
example is uh you know the reason why it
was so memorable is because the uh the
students were doing something uh they
were they were observing the raising
they were given an activity to do they
weren't just being uh elected and what
i'm saying is that you know lecture
isn't valuable people have given some
examples of some very memorable lectures
they had
it's just that is that the best use of
when humans get together a lot of these
very entertaining very inspiring
lecturers uh they you know i'm coming
here as someone who's made 3 000
lectures on youtube so i'm not i'm not
saying that they're they're they're not
valuable i'm just saying that they they
they could maybe be best used uh
off uh when you're not in the classroom
in the classroom you should do things
like that you know expose people to new
experiences make them think about it
have a two-way conversation i agree
because in teaching mindfulness i do
have a didactic and then an experiential
portion and during during the didactic
portions i do try to limit it to 12
minutes or so because i know what
happens and people don't pay attention
so uh interesting thanks very much for
the call richard uh but the the uh that
amount of time is that
is that
time span that that that ability to
focus for uh 10 to 18 minutes does that
cover other aspects of interaction as
well
you know i haven't seen uh studies on
that but i i would believe that that's
probably the case uh you know even in
our in our organization we're not for
profit but you know there's 36 people
who work with me uh we kind of you know
we eat our own dog food we say look if
we ever have a meeting no one should be
talking for more than three minutes if
you're talking for more than three
minutes it's a lecture make a video
we'll watch it at our own time and pace
and people can ask you questions when we
get together so uh you have to do that
as well
the then the space of these interactive
meetings uh presumably people can
concentrate a little longer
you know i mean humans humans can have
we've all had hours long conversations
and enjoyed ourselves and that's
actually where we learned a lot a lot of
what we learned from is from
conversations with other people uh and
and and that obviously can go on well
beyond 10 minutes or even an hour uh
because you are actively engaged your
brain is actively processing and
thinking of new things let's see we get
one more caller in uh this is uh
jennifer jennifer's on the line with us
from orange county
hello hi jennifer hi so um
i had a disability and society class as
a actually was a psychology class in
undergrad and i really remember very
little from undergraduate school
but
there was a
guest speaker who had cerebral palsy and
it was my first experience
really hearing from a person who had
cerebral palsy before that
my um i had no idea that their brains
functioned exactly the same way that a
normal person functions it was just
their muscles and their bodies just
didn't work the same and they weren't
able to communicate the same way
and being in that room there was
probably over 200 people in that lecture
and but the the professor
did such an amazing job of bringing
people in
and
engaging the class and changing
perspectives um
and it was just and then she another
thing that she did
is she
had us in in the midst of our lecture
uh walk around campus and picture
ourselves in a wheelchair
and
then come back to the room and talk
about what that might have been like if
we actually were in a wheelchair and how
we would have gotten around so
experiencing something as well as just
being lectured to jennifer thanks very
much for your time thank you
one last email this from janice in
scottsdale a professor of philosophy at
eisenhower college in seneca falls new
york was assigned the day's world
studies lecture to our sophomore class
approximately 100 students the topic was
zen buddhism he went up to the podium
and stood there in complete and utter
silence looking at us for 50 minutes
salman khan thanks very much for your
time today too
thanks for having me it's the talk of
the nation from npr news